[Music]
zombies no you like fries and you again
no no no it's bedtime my little Angela
open Hotel Transylvania okay enjoy this
monster of a tale called Walt the first
way up north on a night without a Meg a
wolf pause did you just ask Alexa to
open Hotel Transylvania and you can
listen to a story with your little
monster what can I help you with Lord of
Darkness I'm looking for a date the date
is Friday July 13th no no I want to meet
someone understood you want to eat dim
sum don't you get it I want to go on a
date I'm lonely I understand you want
Bologna
don't many eyes though few eyes not into
Pentacles dad you're stressed out from
working too hard
you need a vacation from running
everyone else's vacation and I know just
how to fix it where are we going
[Music]
come on there's so much to do you could
go scuba diving try some exotic foods or
just enjoy the view maybe you'll find
your own fireworks on the cruise it's
not The Love Boat Frank you must be the
one and only Dracula
hey do BD Shula a coup BB there's
something about an accent that makes a
man sound so intelligent
you were right great-grandfather van
Helsing monsters are disgusting they
have no idea what's about to happen to
them
all going according to plan
[Music]
there is something about that woman I
don't trust the food here is to die for
must have been garlic in the guacamole
that's deadly for you hey was that you
[Music]
oh no blog is gonna do
[Music]